[Music]
very busy actor you're in the business
you have kids do they understand what it
is you do I kind of cuz I have kids and
I almost prefer that they didn't know
that I did and then sometimes they see
me on TV and I feel like it's weird do
your kids understand they think it's
strange that you're an actor yeah I
think they think I'm a bit of a clown
you know they we we're on the Mindy
project we're doing this we just did
this episode called the triathlon and I
was unfortunately written in a speedo
right I was taking over the swimming
portion of the triathlon so stupidly I
went outside of my house my wife took
the kids out and I went out back and I
got a tan but it was a sunburn right so
people said you know what you can do you
could spray tan I don't know have you
ever gotten it yes I got a spray tan
what like for a bid on the show for
charity I said I'd get cornrows in a
spray tan and they I did it because we
raised money for charity but I got the
spray tan and it's unbelievably invasive
yes yes incredibly invasion yes my my
wife was out for the night and I had my
three-year-old and my four-year-old to
myself and then this woman comes to the
house that I'm just meeting for the
first time and she she brings me
upstairs into my my bathroom my kids are
watching some cartoon or Dena and she
takes out a tent or there's almost like
a cage and she says okay you just take
off all your clothes and I'll spray you
down you know I said do you want me to
cover my penis or you want to give it a
sock or you know what do you want me to
do
that's she's like nah you know I've seen
it all I'm good if you're good I'm good
so I was like okay fine so you know you
stand you stand and it's like completely
naked and you don't okay I'm completely
nude you know you know when you go
through the security in the airport I
was standing like this and and my
four-year-old walks and she she says can
you cup your balls can you lift your
balls all right you know sorry so I'm
like this I'm like this please it's my
birth I'm so that's a and she and my
four-year-olds saying what are you doing
by the way the machines very loud the
tanning machine so this is a traumatic
experience for your photo you walk in
you're naked holding yourself and
getting shot in the groin with a laser
yeah no yeah that's that's crazy
he said can what are you doing and I I'm
getting a spray tan so I just try to
explain it to me say can we get one good
one so I I think my kids think I'm a bit
of a clown well it sounds like you are
you're not shy then about nudity if
you're willing to you know yet be that
exposed for you know for a stranger I
mean you've you've done nude scenes and
movies and things like that so you're
not self-conscious I have yeah I have I
you know it's I've done it and plays a
lot it and when you're in a play you can
you're backstage and you could kind of
you could fluff a bit you know
you know I mean no I don't know what you
mean you can maybe well you're saying is
you can get yourself into a state where
you'll be more impressive exactly
exactly
in in in the movies or at least that I
did this movie called 28 hotel rooms and
I was nude for a large amount of the
time and and the takes went on for a
really long time so yeah you couldn't
fluff and so but then what happens is
the other day my wife she was online and
she pointed out a picture and she said
look this is a picture of you completely
naked from 28 hotel rooms and my penis
was about this this big in the pictures
that's a problem that you you're forever
on the internet with with you know it
was very cold and you can't explain that
anybody very cold dead you might want to
say that first yes for you get to that
part yes you want to say it was really
cold I was in an accident yes and then
you get to that do that and then explain
yeah no you're right yeah but it's out
there for all time on the internet it's
out there forever you're and you're
wondering how did this man make kids
with that
[Laughter]